the increase in human activities is
having a growing impact on our seas
oceans and coastlines and vice versa
what happens in the seas and oceans has
a huge impact on human activity let's
think about the impact of marine life on
fishermen's livelihoods for instance
even small changes in ocean currents can
mean milder or more severe seasons even
a long way from the sea understanding
these phenomena requires careful
observation of the marine world there's
already a lot of data on this but a
large number of public authorities
research centers and industries maintain
separate databases maps of marine
sediments or habitats stop at national
boundaries this fragmentation is a
burden on the marine economy the
European Commission aims to improve
matters to save money for those who use
data to stimulate innovation and to
reduce uncertainty in the seas behavior
through its initiative marine knowledge
2020 this will be done through a set of
targeted initiatives that allow these
observations and data to be channeled
through a set of Internet portals
these portals are mainly for use by
professionals but the data are also
being fed into a European atlas of the
seas which will progressively improve
awareness of the seas among the general
public and clarify European legislation
that affects marine space such as
protected areas and fishing limits